we've got something very cool for you
cool with a capital c
for the first time we are getting a look
at the new race car for the michael
jordan owned nascar team
called 2311 racing ahead of its debut on
the track next year
the nba legend announced the formation
of the new team last month alongside
co-owner and current nascar
driver superstar denny hamlin also this
morning toyota is unveiling its
partnership with the team
bubba wallace will take the wheel of the
new car it's pretty pairing nascar's
only full-time black driver
and it's only black principal team owner
bubba wallace and denny hamlet are at
the charlotte motor speedway for an
interview that you'll see first
on cbs this morning bubba welcome back
to cbs this morning
denny it's really good to see you good
morning thank you guys
thank you bubba let's start with you
it's a new chapter in your life congrats
on that and you're making history too
can you share with us how you're feeling
and how you're processing it all
yeah i'm still processing it every day
this is an exciting opportunity
uh it's been put in front of me that i
have to capitalize on being a part of a
team with with michael jordan and denny
hamlin
uh 2311 partnership with toyota it's uh
it's coming together quite nice and
and next year can't get here soon enough
so um i'm just excited for the
opportunity that's that's the biggest
thing
just gotta make sure i do my part
deliver each and every time out next
year
i know bubba aren't we all ready for
2020 to be oba
oba h come on 20 21.
denny so i know you and michael jordan
are long-time friends
how did this come about did he call you
you call him and say hey i got an idea
what happened uh uh yeah it was uh
somewhat by accident but uh i i think
there were some rumors floating around
about me and him
um starting or being a part of a team to
begin with and
and uh he obviously said you know fake
news but if you want to make a real news
let me know so
uh it was just one of those things where
i was kind of well wait a minute
let's let's have a chat and so i flew
down to florida to to meet with them
uh within a couple days and we just went
through that whole process vetting
process over the next 10 days to 14 days
to
make sure we we had everything in line
that we could get it done and and
obviously once we did
uh things started moving pretty quickly
so it was uh
great that uh you know obviously our
friendship
turned into a partnership uh with him
with the whole jordan brand sponsoring
me and michael jordan
but then you know turning it into a
nascar ownership now
uh is obviously historic and then did
you say you know who we should call
bubba wallace
there's there's no doubt from my mind i
i believe that boba's outperformed
um you know the equipment that he's had
week in week out
um there's been many times i've been
passed on research i'm like
i should not be running right here uh
and
and he's just uh he's getting the most
out of it so i think this is a great
opportunity for him
to return to the toyota family uh a
family that he's been with
early in his career as well and uh this
is an exciting partnership for everyone
i know i'm very excited about this bubba
but you've been with your old family for
a while when you got the call
was it something you had to think about
or was it an immediate yes for you
i definitely had to think about it um
and and i was actually at the shop
yesterday with the rpm family
uh talking to most of the guys in the
shop talking to my my a-team guys and
um you know it's still it's still tough
and you kind of
got to accept the fact that you know
things happen and things happen for a
reason
and i'm excited to move on but i kept
reinstating we still have two solid
races for us coming up here at
martinsville
in phoenix to close out the year that we
have to capitalize on so
as much as i'm ready for the future next
year my mind is still on
the two races in 2020 to get through and
finish out the best way possible pass
denny on restarts make him mad just to
fuel the fire even more for next year
yeah you and michael jordan together
though that's quite a one-two punch
do you feel uh added pressure i don't
know if you saw the
last dance documentary did you by chance
see that
yeah i prefer it as a two-three punch
that'd be a little bit better fitting
for the team
yeah very nice very nice do you feel
added pressure because you know he's
such a competitor
and he's a competitor he likes to win as
do you do you feel
added pressure with that
uh i think look at the car i'm driving
right now iconic number 43.
now we're switching over to the iconic
number 23. so pressure is
kind of my middle name and and i guess
i'll just have to deliver the best i can
um you know i think i perform well under
pressure look at
a couple months ago everything that was
going on off the racetrack we put some
together put together some of our best
races
uh and so i'm excited for the
opportunity excited to have mj in my
corner have denny there
yeah somebody i can lean on learn from
and and you know also go out and compete
again so we can
make this team better and better each
and every race out so i know it's going
to take some time and
to get our feet underneath us but we're
ready to walk out of the door swinging
danny we should say listen you are no
slouch either when it comes
uh behind the wheel you're one daytona
500 three times you're a nascar hall of
famer
so help me understand this because
you're still going to be racing too
so are you and bubba competing against
each other are you all
sort of on the same team how is this
working
yeah i mean it's a different dynamic i
you know this hasn't been done
uh for 20 years or so you know since
dale earnhardt so
uh but yeah i mean we're going to be
competitors each and every sunday i'm
going to want to win
for my fedex toyota team and and bob is
going to want to try to win for his team
uh and so i think that we we got to
maintain that competitive fire
i know but you're always part of the
team push us but you own part of the
team
yeah i mean that's what makes it a
little complicated but uh i obviously
know that uh
it's in my best interest to go out and
win uh for myself so
that's that's the good part about it you
know starting this team
really for me was about you know what do
i do with
once my career is over the driving
career is over uh i'll i'll
definitely have a much bigger role in
the team obviously above
ownership itself so i think that this is
a
it's a good way for me to continue my
partnership with toyota somewhere and
i've been with now for 13 years had over
40 wins with
this is just a way to carry on that
legacy well guys i've never been to a
nascar race i have to say i really want
to go i've been to formula one because
i'm friends with lewis hamilton i think
they're so exciting and so different
than anything i've ever seen but i
really now want to come to nascar so
i'm going to figure this out in 2021.
thank you absolutely the opportunity is
perfect all right thank you both
cheering you both on thank you bubba and
denny for your time this morning